I want to remind you about history back
in history exists no that's not the
reminder back of specific historical
happening back in 2014 Russia invaded
Crimea and at the time Crimea was a
region of Ukraine and Russia annexed
Crimea after crimeans supposedly voted
in favor of the annexation in
understandably disputed official
election results an election which took
place during an occupation by Russian
forces and of course tabulated by Russia
and so far there have really been pretty
limited consequences for what Russia did
in Ukraine with Crimea one of the
consequences was that Russia was kicked
out of the g8 which was made the g7
Donald Trump recently said that he wants
Russia back in the g7 making it once
again the g8 and when he was questioned
about will hold on Russia did invade
Crimea like there is a reason why the g7
is the g7 rather than the g8 and it's
because of what Russia did Trump
basically shrugged and said that was
under Obama's watch Obama didn't do
anything about it back in 2014 so insert
something something as far as the logic
that explains it but I guess that means
Donald Trump isn't going to be doing
anything about Russia annexing Crimea
that's the history more recently Trump
said something when he was I believe
leaving the North Korea summit in
Singapore he said something along the
lines of basically Crimea is essentially
Russian because everyone in Crimea
speaks Russian that was Trump's
explanation and that is a mind-numbing
ly dumb comment to make Mexico doesn't
belong to Spain right now and if someone
said Mexico's basically a Spanish
because they speak Spanish well there
are historical reasons for that but
Mexico isn't Spain or listen people in
the United States speak English reason
why is because of Britain isn't the
United States actually part of the
United Kingdom any normal person would
see that this is an absurd assertion to
make hard to make a dumber argument but
the fact that Trump made the argument
that hey everyone's
Crimea is Russian it made it on to
Russia 24 television Russian state media
in Russia which thrillingly declared
that Trump is doing a great thing and
that Crimea is theirs on the basis of
Donald Trump saying this and it is yet
another one of these examples of
authoritarian countries around the world
just loving what Donald Trump is doing
and I'm gonna play a short clip for you
it is in Russian so I don't want to play
too much of it but just to give you an
idea you will hear them saying [ __ ]
[ __ ] quite a bit and a just jubilant
over Donald Trump statement about this
Donald Trump's Castle idiom well sure in
your case Tokra merely a ruse Kim but
among stochastic toriyama varied paruz
kiss up shared a diplomatic skills Tosh
Nika Yossi of linear pursue solution on
pros repetitive remarriage Guinea in a
stronger deal nasa meetable so similar
give cannot conquer bacon lover Emer una
trampa taxes adult syrup Rossum which
she moolah the rebels who seem your
Casilla darkness Ukraine presidents
Castle idioms to Ukraine Eve let's admit
some chrome pyramix transmitters castles
Toshi
Gnaeus 'no will the commentary Trampas
chasm food co alone signal easy route or
ready column at Koinonia finished even
each new political Sarah the Le dome Nia
treat inoperable procurement 0 so once
again the theme is Trump is drawn to
praising and trying to befriend
authoritarian dictators and conversely
the countries that are praising Trump
are mostly the same types of countries
its North Korea its Russia and at the
same time our relationships with real
allies like Canada and the European
Union and European countries are in
absolute and total shambles and what
what I hope is that future generations
if the records from this era don't get
burned up and destroyed my hope is that
future generations are going to wonder
how was this allowed to happen how did
we allow it to get this bad I'm not
going to have an answer and the the
possibility that there will be no answer
is really really scary to me let's take
a quick break give us a like on facebook
at facebook.com slash david pakman show
much more after this